Suegra o cuñado, nuestro formatín tóxico de cabecera favorito.
Vale mucho.
Una pregunta, dos opciones y una sola respuesta.
La peor.
Vale.
La que menos nos gusta.
Bien.
La que menos nos convence.
Sí.
Es el reverso negativo de papá-mamá.
Básicamente.
Vale.
Para todo aquel que nos esté escuchando por primera vez, viendo en YouTube por primera
vez, nosotros te lo facilitamos de esa manera.
Para que entendáis un poquito la dinámica, he escogido una primera pregunta que os va
a encantar.
Es de Victor Carras.
Todas estas preguntas nos las dejan en Instagram en Arrobas somos pizarritas, donde te recomendamos
que nos sigas.
Si lo eres, somos.
La pregunta de Victor es…
No.
Si quieres mejorar tu carrera…
Ok.
…¿qué es peor?
¿Irte a Arabia o al Manchester United?
Me encanta.
Claramente al Manchester United es peor.
Sí, peor.
Vas a jugar menos.
El club es un desastre.
Clima.
En Arabia te van a pagar muy bien.
Vas a jugar.
Tu transfer igual no llega.
Bueno, esto es si te vas haciendo las cosas mal.
Bueno, bueno…
Que también hemos hablado poco de…
Con el United igual tampoco llega.
Claro.
Bueno, es que esa es otra.
Y…
Empate.
Llenas el buche y ya tu próximo paso puede ser la mejor decisión a nivel deportivo.
O sea, tú…
Arabia todos los días del año.
Salvo United.
O sea, United es mucho peor.
United es mucho peor.
Yo United es peor, sí.
San Juan es en la Premier, pero…
A ver, a ver si juegas.
Sí, pero es que es un bajón.
O sea, es un bajón.
A nivel deportivo, peor United.
Yo no así diría a Arabia.
A ver, si te dan igual los derechos humanos, pues claro, puedes regir.
Bueno, claro, sí.
Si te dan igual los derechos deportivos…
Claro, claro.
Depende de cómo lo empuques.
Rafa Ascote.
¿Qué es peor, la venta de Uche o la de Dodi Luquevacchio?
Uf…
Luquevacchio.
¿Por qué?
Fue futbolista diferencial marcando muchos goles la temporada pasada.
Vale.
A mí me parece mucho peor la de Uche.
Yo estoy con…
O sea, Uche…
Bueno, escuchábamos a Toni Muñoz haciendo el balance de mercado en la presentación
de Abu Kamara y le preguntaba ¿no podías haber encontrado algo más para sustituir a
Uche?
Y dice que lo vendimos el último día de la 10 de la noche.
El Sevilla ya tenía perfiles en plantilla para sustituir a Luquevacchio.
De peor nivel, por supuesto.
No tiene un duro el Sevilla.
Pero está la situación contemplada y creo que en la medida de lo posible bien resuelta.
El Getafe ni siquiera le encuentra a Uche cuando llevan todo el verano queriendo venderlo.
Igual el reemplazo es Abkar.
Se lo inventa a Bordalas.
Se empieza a jugar en largos…
Onayu.
Algo parecido y ya está.
O Da Vinci, puesto a se inventar.
Sí, claro.
Yo diría la de Uche, sí, también.
Vale.
Igual el recambio puede ser el primo de Dejano.
Claro.
Que es liso.
¿Eh?
Ahí está.
Se da en la mano.
Momento muy radiofónico, efectivamente.
Creo que a veces la radio tiene que pasar a un plano secundario.
Como los derechos humanos en Arabia.
David Esturillo, 10.
¿Qué es peor?
¿El vestuario del Valladolid 24-25 o el del Mallorca 25-26?
Esto es canela en rama.
Porque es verdad.
Todavía los jugadores del Mallorca no se han peleado de forma pública.
Pero sabemos que ha pasado de forma privada.
Hombre, gracias.
Ayer habíamos en Puzzel antes de que Luis Pérez y la Tasa se zumbasen.
Luis Pérez y una entrevista en verano de tres horas explicando el tema.
Sí.
¿Molulu?
Lo del Valladolid parece mucho peor.
Sí, porque además…
El Mallorca, aún peleándose, saca 18 puntos.
¿Qué decir?
Ya, pero…
Es que también tiene más.
El vestuario del Valladolid, aunque utilizas el poder de la amistad,
también la plantilla es la que es.
Y también se puede ir a hacer una broma.
Que siguen siendo los centros muy justos.
Bueno, pero estamos hablando de esto también.
Que el vestuario es peor.
A nivel de equipo estoy de acuerdo.
Se juntan y juegan más o menos bien los del Mallorca.
A nivel de vestuario, yo digo Mallorca.
Igual estoy sobrereaccionando a lo actual.
Yo creo que sí.
Es que el Valladolid ya tenemos la confirmación de, primero,
pelea vista por todo el mundo en cámara, descenso…
Para mí, el Valladolid.
De cierto, tenía preparado una anahuelada.
Que es que tiene destino ya Enrique Silva,
que es este chico que vino del Lyon para por hacer una vuelta.
Hombre, sí, el lateral.
Sí, ha acabado jugando en el Turanto Bus de Azerbaiyán.
¿Es la final de visión de Azerbaiyán?
Entiendo que sí.
Está el fútbol a hacer y tirando la casa por la ventana.
Ehh…
Peor lo del Mallorca actual.
Está cuarto.
En primera.
Esta temporada, sí.
De cuatro.
Aunque el nombre de Juanmi Latasa, insuperable.
Y se dice poco.
Ojo, balón de oro, Latasa.
Porque no una cesión.
Juan Miguel Latasa Fernández de Laíos.
Superado.
Nombre de torero, eh.
Podría John Cuombre.
Hombre, que gente con pasas.
Pero lo toreo bastante.
A ver, Rullog97.
Rullog.
¿El Liverpool Pre-Club o el Athletic Presimione?
¿Qué era peor?
El Athletic Presimione.
Y eso que vosotros no lo habéis vivido con SuperFlight.
El Liverpool Pre-Club pelea una Premier.
Ya, bueno, pero el Athletic Presimione también gana un Europa League.
A veces se olvida un poquito los años de Kike.
Dimensión es diferente.
Que no, no, yo estoy de acuerdo.
El Atlético Madrid…
El Liverpool Pre-Club pasó Suárez por ahí, eh.
Bueno, y Torres por Atlético.
A ver, es que claro, ¿el Pre dónde se establece?
¿En el año anterior?
No, yo creo que se refieren a…
O sea, no es justo el año anterior, sino el ciclo anterior.
La etapa anterior.
O sea, no cien años de historia, pero no el día 1.
Claro, es que se ha de establecerlo.
Si íbamos a los años de Torres, Torres también pasó por el Liverpool.
Y tenía un equipazo con Rafa Benítez.
Ya, pero…
O sea, tuvo…
Realmente el Liverpool tiene cuatro o cinco años de ser un equipo nefasto.
Pero no mucho más.
Sí que no, que yo estoy de acuerdo con el Athletic.
Es que la gente todavía se olvida.
Yo entiendo que tú puedes cuestionar a Simeone y puedes ver ciertas historias.
Y el club ha evolucionado y ha cambiado.
Gracias a Simeone.
Pero lo pre era muy duro, eh.
Sí, sí.
Muy duro.
Nico Díaz, hablando de dureza, en clave Sevilla.
¿Marcao o Niangshu?
Buff.
Niangshu.
Niangshu porque ha jugado más.
Marcao.
Y porque le ha costado más pasta, ¿no?
Bueno, pero Marcao bajó el sueldo.
Marcao bajó el sueldo, Niangshu ha dicho que…
La renovación de Marcao permitió escribir dos fútbolistas.
Los partidos de Niangshu fueron demenciales.
Niangshu todavía tiene un poco la esperanza y dice, bueno, a ver si con 28…
Sí, claro.
Marcao.
A ver si algún día el niño se va de casa.
Marcao maravillado.
SamuRF18, de Sevilla a Valencia.
¿Negredo o Cavani?
Espera.
¿Qué fue peor?
Peor, Cavani.
Te honra.
Honor.
Es que es muy bonito el gol de Negredo contra el Monaco.
Luego Negredo hizo muchísimas cosas malas en Valencia para empezar a estar constantemente
pasado de peso, pelearse con Nuno.
Y aún así fue un fichaje, además…
Si hubiera sido el Negredo del City, habría sido un fichaje, pero no estuvo nunca cerca
de esa versión y el Valencia iba sobrado de nueves.
Y aún así…
La primera vuelta de Cavani no es mala.
Pero claro, es que lo de la segunda fue terrible.
El chico de Bocas Juniors lo vio claro.
Sí, sí.
Pobre.
Javi Gonzado.
¿Chimi en el Betis o Tecatito en el Sevilla?
Chimi en el Betis.
De acuerdo.
Sí, Chimi en el Betis.
Tecatito tiene el componente de la lesión, pero antes era un jugador importante.
Es verdad que cobra más Tecatito, pero es que el Chimi transmite una negatividad en el Betis ya.
Sale y igual soy yo, pero…
¿Os acordáis la imagen aquella en la República Checa con los aficionados diciendo
sí, sí, yo les digo que peleen a los jugadores y tal, como también echando un poquito de fuego al vestuario?
No, no.
Fue un fichaje extraño porque no encaja mucho con ese vestuario.
Fue en invierno, ¿no? Fue en invierno.
Sí, sí.
Una semanita complicada para el chico.
Le largan en Pamplona.
Sí, sí.
Kuko MH.
Estás de fútbol en general, ¿vale?
¿Qué es peor recibir gol en el 44, o sea, justo antes de tu descanso?
O el psicológico.
Sí, o en el 46, justo después. ¿Qué es peor?
Bueno, yo en el 46 los querría matar a todos.
Totalmente acuerdo.
Y me parece que no puedes intervenir.
Es verdad que emocionalmente el del 44 te deja un poquito bluff, pero el del 46…
Te tira todo por los solos.
No es un gol, pero la batallita de Mourinho con Balotelli en el Inter…
Ah, sí, la de la tarjeta marina.
… que creo que es, que solo tiene a Balotelli de nueve, se va con amarilla al descanso,
se tiran los 15 minutos del descanso y dicen a él,
Mario, no presiones. Si te dicen algo, no contestas.
A la primera, pum, segundo amarilla y para afuera.
Si sabes cómo me pongo, ¿pa' qué me invitas?
Bueno, no tenía con qué cambiarlo.
Sí, peor el 46.
Es que normalmente se hizo lo contrario.
Pero me parece un poco topiquero.
No, pero es que el del 44 lo puedes solucionar medianamente.
El del 46 ya, uf, hay que remar mucho.
Carlos Comt. En el Real Madrid. ¿Qué fue peor, lo de Lucas Hilo o lo de Nuri Sahin?
A nivel de excepción, en el Nuri Sahin, el Dortmund me volvió loquísimo.
Me encanta ese Dortmund con Cagaua, Lucas Barrios, Lewandowski, Gotsi y tal.
Muy duro meter aquí a Sahin.
Joder. Yo creo que Lucas Silva mucho peor.
Es que en el Nuri Sahin no es fan. Nada, pero…
Noci. Pero Lucas Silva también…
Es un poco como lo de Kaká también, que llega al lesionado.
Lucas Silva también tiene el problema ese.
De corazón. Lucas Silva…
No ha tenido ni una sola temporada en el nivel de lo que fue en el Nuri Sahin.
Sí, pero están preguntando en el Madrid.
Quiero decir, no juega ninguno.
Ocho partidos, tres titularidades.
Lucas Silva. ¿Y Sahin?
Sahin, espérate. De banda…
De banda por ahí, sí.
¿Por los dos? ¿Qué más da?
Peor ha sido Reynier.
Pues mira… No he mutado, ¿no?
No, no llego a jugar.
Te estoy hablando de Liga. Cuatro partidos de Liga.
Nuri Sahin con el Madrid.
Y dos del titular. Sahin.
Lo de Sahin. ¿Tenemos gol de falta antes?
Me suena. Es que me suena con camiseta de los detalles dorados.
Los detalles dorados, ¿no?
La temporada de la Liga de los récords.
Es que también es igual.
No recuerdo.
Juega en Madrid. Que era complicado.
Pero Nuri Sahin en el Dortmund era un escándalo.
Entonces, si entra o…
Vale. Cero goles.
Nuri Sahin que jugó en el Liverpool Club también.
Sí, exactamente. De ahí fue.
Exactamente.
Joel Hurtado.
Esto es más en clave español, pero podría ser en general.
Alejo Beliz o Chedira.
Waliit.
Waliit tiene cosas.
Luego dices no sé pa qué, pero Chedira no tiene cosas.
¿Dónde está Waliit?
Pues está en el sasuolo.
No ha arrancado muy lozano.
Te has contestado solo.
Pues que no me vayáis a tirar esta pared.
Ya después de cuatro temporadas sé que paredes…
Ni siquiera de llano.
Igual sí.
Estoy muy esquinao para la pared.
Ahora el problema es del entrenador.
Se han hecho virales los retos de Waliit en TikTok.
En TikTok.
Hay gente que sube TikToks con las hojas de los libros de Buscando a Walii.
Ah.
Para que lo busques.
Bueno.
¿Te tiras tres minutos viendo eso?
Claro.
Una vez vi uno que fue a una biblioteca, coge un libro
de dónde está Walii, escaneo la página,
tapo a Walii,
pegó encima y lo volví a dejar.
Un sociopata.
Claro. Entonces,
en una biblioteca tienes un rato libre,
puedes ir a la biblioteca y puedes ir buscando a Walii.
Y no, encuentras.
Aritz Vitorica.
Como cantante.
Cantante.
Sergio Ramos o Gesé.
Gesé.
No, Gesé mejor.
Yo creo que tenía una marca.
J.M. tenía una marca.
La Roja Juega en Casa.
Es que es la canción con Niña Pastor y un muy buen.
Ha dicho como cantante.
Zidane floja.
Si tú lo analizas como una tiradera,
pero no dan nombre, no sé qué.
Se pregunta de orden.
Y dice, no, por suerte en tiro no.
No, no, no.
Y dice que se ve más cerca de ganar el Nemi
que la final de Champions como entrenador.
Que quieres ser entrenador.
Os digo una cosa. ¿Sabríais mencionar algún tema de Gesé?
Yo sé su nombre artístico.
Yo le gramos sedos. Ya está.
No, no.
Argumento ganador.
Luis Camel.
No me parece exactamente un suegro o cuñado,
pero lo han preguntado varios.
Porque lo han preguntado a Mario.
Me faltaba uno.
La audiencia manda.
A los tres que no se escuchan, ellos mandan.
Messi en el Paris Saint-Germain o Cristiano en el United.
¿Qué fue peor?
Messi.
Cristiano en el United.
Cristiano en el United estuvo cerca de ser
máximo goleador de la Premier.
Messi fue máximo goleador de la Liga francesa.
Me acabo de decir un triple.
Los datos de Messi.
Yo creo que es un triplón.
A mí me parece peor lo de Cristiano.
Yo diría que también.
Cristiano vuelve a un club
donde fue muy feliz.
Es que Messi se va al Paris Saint-Germain.
Eso sería como el fichaje.
Creo que están preguntando al rendimiento.
Interpretas tú.
¿Qué fue peor?
Messi en el Paris Saint-Germain o Cristiano en el United.
Con las cifras que marca en París,
son 11 en la primera temporada
y 2 y 21 en la segunda.
Entre todas las competiciones.
No solo la Liga francesa.
Cristiano Ronaldo dejó un segundito.
Cristiano Ronaldo
en todas las competiciones.
A Messi nadie le pedía ganar de la Champions
y lo de el PSG en Champions.
Messi fue lamentable.
24 goles en la primera temporada.
La segunda ya 3.
Bueno, 3 más que Messi en su segunda.
Bueno, pues esto es un suero cuñado.
Yo creo que la entrevista del Apetite Fruit
es la entrevista que hace nada más
marcharse a Arabia con
Piers Morgan.
Ah, vale, no te había entendido.
Bueno, Piers Morgan tampoco lo pilló en la primera.
Apetite Fruit.
Ríos 19.
Estas sí que son suero cuñados.
A ver.
Directiva del Rayo o del Sevilla.
Del Rayo.
No, pero la del Sevilla.
El Rayo tiene menos alma,
pero inscribe, las cuentas están hechas,
el club es un desastre y tal.
Sí, pero es el Rayo.
El Rayo.
Los trabajadores del Sevilla no se tienen que llevar el menaje
como tú decías lo otro día.
Y el estadio del Ramón Sánchez Pijuan entiendo que están
en mejores condiciones de lo que está el estadio de Vallecos.
Pero no va… O sea, no está súper súper.
El trabajador del Sevilla, por culpa de la directiva,
está más cerca de que le calienten a la salida del Ramón Sánchez Pijuan.
También te digo.
Es duro esto, eh. Sí, sí.
Es duro. Podrían hacer un triangular con Méridon.
Podrían.
Podemos hablar de cuál es el equipo que está jugando Europa y cuál es el que no.
Es que al final…
Es que el equipo, deportivamente, va para adelante.
Luego todo lo demás ya se ha vuelto muy cuestionable.
¿Qué va para atrás? Jaime Moya, 14.
¿Qué fue peor? ¿El 7-1 a Brasil, de Alemania, evidentemente,
o el 8-2 del Bayern al Barça?
Yo creo que el 7-1.
El 7-1 es en tu casa, en tu mundial…
El 7-1… Sin Neymar…
El 7-1 tiene más excusa.
No llega Neymar al partido.
Ah, bueno. Y no llega Thiago Silva tampoco.
Ya, bueno. Y en el Barça está Nelson Semedo.
Ya, pero es una decisión del Barça.
¿Qué más lo pasó?
Este día lo pasó.
Con Thiago Silva y con Neymar, yo creo que 7-1 les calga.
¿Te puedo contraargumentar? A ver.
Gran parte de la goleada del Barça
son un poco goles de relleno.
O sea, el Bayern superior, cada 8-2.
Pero hay muchos goles de relleno.
De hecho, Coutinho partilipa tal.
Los de Brasil son en la primera parte.
La primera parte… Es una guadañaza.
Solo hay una en la segunda, creo.
El 1, el gol, es el último.
Bueno, surle es al 7-1
lo que Coutinho al 2-8.
Yo creo que es peor por ser mundial,
ser Brasil…
En tu casa…
La vida fue buena… El Mineirazo.
La vida fue buena con Coutinho.
Que sufrió una y dijo
«Para que veas que no son todos palos,
te dan una zanahoria».
Mira, los minutos de los goles de Alemania
son el 11, el 23, el 24, el 25, el 29.
Y luego el doble de surle
en la segunda parte, 69-79.
El gol de Oscar en el último minuto.
Mira que yo he defendido el nivel y el rendimiento
de Samy Kevira.
Ese partido de Samy Kevira es…
Es Dios de la Tierra.
Es un tractor.
El de Fred fue tremendo también.
Ese partido es maravilla.
Lozano Raúl, dependes del fair play
para clasificar como antiguamente.
¿Vale? ¿Cómo?
A mí me denlo al Chimi.
Al Chimi.
Porque al Chimi
creo que ocurriría como Murillo con Balotelli.
Por favor.
Que estamos clasificados.
Simplemente no metas un palo.
En términos de fair play te puedo hacer la de Danjuma Mbutarque.
Sí.
Chimi, piernas frescas.
Cabeza. Mente fría.
Pues toma entrada
a la altura de las rodillas.
Y ya la última de nuestro queridísimo editor
del canal de YouTube, Regista13.
Alexander.
Ídolo. Os va a gustar.
¿Levantarse temprano o irse a dormir tarde
tras los directos de Champions?
¿Qué es peor? Eh…
Ah…
A ver, yo es que me gusta mucho irme a dormir tarde.
Rápido. Ahora no me estoy yendo a dormir tarde
pero le estoy cogiendo el gusto a madrugón.
Irse a dormir tarde. A mí me trascocaba mucho.
Pero irse a dormir tarde. Venga, va.
Yo no pienso contestar a esto.
Porque… Vamos.
Cuando puedes decir y… Y no.
Efectivamente.
Yo haré cuñado en definitiva.